[Music]
have you ever tweeted something that you
regretted i think all of them that's why
i deleted my twitter
[ __ ] wasteland i deleted my twitter
[ __ ] i think last year i was like man
i don't know what i tweeted back then
i'm scared yeah i've been on twitter
since i was like 20 or something and you
know you say the craziest [ __ ] yeah
cause you think i'm crazy now man
i gotta get rid of this [ __ ] dude i
don't know what the hell is going on
back there why do think bart's crazy now
he's like i don't know if i'm gonna see
all these model movies guys and i'm like
whoa
whoa i watched the last spider man did
you what'd you think i thought it was
really good did everyone see it and i
don't want to say nah
no spoilers no spoilers you didn't see
it right the third of the series
you like marvel oh [ __ ] did you watch
the other two tom holland ones no i
didn't oh you gotta watch those two
first i am going to take out the
spiderman article that i have in
tomorrow
i haven't watched it either
i watched it but very good that that's
very good before we all have to get on
the same page watch the same [ __ ] okay
so pat pabst
pabst blue ribbon
unfortunately had to delete a tweet you
mean the beer company pbr
pabst blue ribbon deletes a tweet about
eating ass
saying that it was in poor judgment why
[ __ ] them that's amazing what's wrong
with that yeah what's wrong with you
it's a take yeah what'd they actually
say about it the beer company deletes a
tweet about eating why
for most people why do you expect like
great behavior out of a beer company so
if you're not
you know what i mean
and uh a shitty beer company like two
dollar beers yeah um by the way i would
love to be sponsored you know what i
think it is it's time for uh political
take right all right
i got a thought coming from the left
side
i think um
they don't
want to be you know you know
they're being homophobic is what it is
you know what i mean like
eating ass is wonderful
for men and women alike
and then um pat's blue ribbon guys they
they're like that guy
that's what happened joe can you can you
first help to define eating answers for
people who don't know what that is i
can't use any of these hats for that so
uh
uh you go like this you you you have
them bend over or you can where you have
them bend over or you better i bend over
yeah either way because that's more real
that's not nice it's a girl
he's playing the girl one one hand on
one cheek anthony's from wales what do
you do yeah
[Laughter]
you open
and then you kiss okay yeah it's like
eating [ __ ] but on the [ __ ] have you
done it or did you just like it done to
you right both ways golden rule man i
swing both ways
do you ever put the tongue in the
butthole i try you try yeah but it
doesn't go in
her butthole's strong it's so tight
wow i don't like that you ever blow the
balloon
how do you blow the balloon you stick a
straw and you try to make a [ __ ]
balloon animal
through intestines uh have you done it
bro
what eat ass yeah yeah you [ __ ] love
it huh
big fan
uh
only if she's enjoying it she has to be
in the mood
yeah so she's enjoying it she's just
like comes home she's grabs a gatorade
you know what yeah i think i want my
[ __ ]
there's a gatorade flavor that does that
oh lemon lime
yeah next time we get my ass we'll eat
now glacier freeze
the glacier freezes the one that's the
one so what did they really say
not drinking this january try eating ass
you weren't [ __ ] kidding
you were [ __ ] kidding that's not even
a great tweet though it's like it's kind
of nice it's about it's about dry
january huh
and then i realize it's serious
sometimes i [ __ ] with you like that
what's wrong with the tweet well it
wasn't funny enough yeah let's see it's
not funny maybe they should have been
like try sucking some dick you know what
would you expect good 2 640 retweets 2
931 quote tweets that's pretty good
seems to be pretty enjoyable this was
posted
by password on the third guys didn't i
tell you guys that [ __ ] rim jobs are
the new [ __ ] you did you tried to
sell that none of us believed it we
didn't buy i am a trendsetter dude like
if eating ass was crypto
bro to the moon i don't i don't like my
butthole lit i think i think the
intention is from an alcohol company
they're uh hating on the idea of the
concept something like dry january
because that means that they're not
drinking beer right so i was like oh
yeah you want to
try eating ass and so i think it has a
comes off from an alcohol company as
something very like if you're into dry
january hey eat ass [ __ ] you know
it's more of that but then i'm taking it
as a compliment like oh yeah that's
awesome okay go [ __ ] yourself dude yeah
joe reads it try eating ass he's like oh
yeah i love that yeah okay
sure
like try eating it homie and i'm like
bro i [ __ ] think i invented it
joe's one of the retweets he's like i
agree yeah i'll do a february march yeah
what are some of the responses on no not
november why don't you go eat a cake
and i'm like yeah red velvet is pretty
awesome
so the first he's optimist dude one of
the first tweets was uh i don't know
what this is about but it's hilarious
and then
the pbr spokesperson needed to really
lay into what it was about what do you
say reading about ass and eating it
about ass and eating it that's funnier
than the original that's funny
hey just so you know so it's about ass
and eating ass
all right that's funny yeah and then uh
and then
later they had to uh
kind of dial it back and they apologized
because they thought oh sorry i meant
eat but yeah what kind of apology was it
like what are they specifying is their
yeah
so they apologize by just walking it
back by saying that they felt like the
tweet the initial tweet was in poor
judgment of what yeah what about eating
ass yeah
they actually believe that it's actually
cool now i would assume it's not in poor
judgment about eating ass i think it
would be important judgment if it
offended people who were trying to
participate in dry january i actually
think that whoever tweeted that is down
to be like yeah eat ass you ass you know
what i mean well yeah and now they're
actually getting canceled they're about
to go out of business for king shaming
wow that would be interesting because i
would be a part of the group that gets
offended for them shaming my craft you
were an optimist minecraft you literally
liked it i i feel a little bit duped
because i thought they were a supporter
of the of the movement and they're not
they're just flipping the game on me
dude like what the [ __ ] you use that as
a offensive term you'll take your two
dollars somewhere else to buy beer
exactly dude
my 1.25 cents i can see that it's the
word try is what the offensive because
it's like so you're saying that people
don't normally do that see there it is
there it is
eating us they're yucking a lot of
people's yum and so that's what i
personally have a problem with that's
why i wanted to bring this to you guys
attention it's like that's like saying
like like oh you're not gonna drink beer
we'll just try eating some
[ __ ] that would have been better
actually that would have been a better
tweak a million times better great sweet
that's one million times better yeah
let's let's go around the store and keep
on thinking about possible alternatives
see where that leads i mean it
definitely is a weird taste to to to
mention eating ass with any type of
consumable product yeah like brain wise
what they should have said in my opinion
not drinking pvr this january try eating
ass it's pretty close
try eating your own ass like that
that yeah maybe that's what it was there
were too many snide comebacks that they
were like we better delete this [ __ ]
because we're getting smoked
we're getting destroyed
oh i see you know what they they
probably wanted to do first like when
they're having this [ __ ] workshop
right they're like you know we should
say is try drinking some piss and
they're like well our beer actually
tastes like piss so it's like no that's
not good it's too close to reality how
about ass oh yeah yeah that's like piss
you know that's like this
it's butt you know
what's pee what's your butt i'm like
where's our hr president oh they're
hanging in the corner they killed
himself
back to the meeting guys oh my god yeah
like back to the meeting who approved
this [ __ ] right like somebody approved
it i think it was one of those people
who get hired to like really like shake
things up some [ __ ]
shake things up yeah and they're like
we need a new marketing edge yeah
comes through
marketing agency and they're like you
know we need some new blood this
company's a bunch of 70 year old man you
know with statistics about like tweets
that talk about eating ass and how it
shoots revenue through the roof and
that's what he's trying to bring he
comes in with a t-shirt that ariel font
says there's no such thing as bad press
exactly
and actually he's probably right yeah
because now we're talking about i
haven't talked about
blue whatever the [ __ ] in a long time
have you guys it's working i have i
guess it's working they give you a free
shot like most bars they do
is it ever considered like a good beer
depending on the phase of life never
dude it was never considered a good deal
i think it's a it's almost like a
novelty beer to drink when you're like
in the uk having like chips and [ __ ]
chips and what if they're in college
it's like dude it's like point five up
from from drinking natty ice fish and
chips fish and chips i was like chips
and dip well i thought
chips did my blue ribbon was like a
nascar yeah i thought it was an american
beer i didn't know it was uk
i just remember going to like uk bars
and stuff like that and they just had a
bunch of passports what they that's what
they used to make at the brewery right
next to barbell it was a pabst blue
ribbon brewery what they made it there
yeah
that's why everybody eats ass there
in commemoration oh that's true they're
american they're from milwaukee
milwaukee
maybe it was an american bar in the uk
i thought it was the official drink for
tractor drivers
you know like i didn't know i think so
yeah that's a good shot yeah they put
peanut butter all over their [ __ ]
i would i would be curious to know
whether or not like actual like fans or
drinkers of pbr were offended or not
because if it was for their demo i think
the only thing they could be offended by
is just how how like it it's opening the
door to get roasted that's it yeah
that's probably exactly what it was
that's the thing we are also in semi
canceled culture 2020 these type stuff
and you see the people that are
canceling aren't the fans it's like
people outside like i'm outraged let me
give them some [ __ ] traffic and views
people who drink miller high life were
offended who follows like beer companies
on social media like that though but
like i feel like steve follows all the
alcohol companies i follow uh
quite a significant amount yes but like
but to the level of like pbr you know
like do you follow any drinks that you
actually drink i need a red bull because
i don't post any drink content
it's [ __ ] bikes in the air [ __ ]
cars in the air yeah yeah
you're gonna support it that's what they
actually a very good example if you
already needs a sport like like wife hit
this guy got the gold medal with
whitehead and people like hey
this ppr is for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you